“They came from beyond the world, from
over the world, from under the world.
They came from inside the
stars and from behind the rain.
They came from the known lands and they
came from the secret places of old.
The vast ones who drank of the nebulae, the small
ones who did not care what happened beyond the
banks of their rivers, the ones who bathed in the
light and the ones who watched from the shadows,
the ones who loved us and
the ones who forgot about us,
the ones who hate us now and the ones who love
us still, the ones who sung with the rats and
the ones who swam with the leviathans, they
came from far and near, they came one and all.
They came to end the world.”
As you may already know from our previous
video in this series, a mysterious being
known only as the Harbinger unlocked SCP-001 -
The Lock - and brought about the Omnipocalypse:
Every single world-destroying
XK Class Scenario on the books,
from Foundation files to the most ancient
mythological tomes, and some we’d never
even imagined, began to come true. A world
flooded with terrifying anomalous activity,
from unfurling skies to giant, nightmarish
animals, was about where we left off.
Now it’s time to open your eyes and wake up.
This is the kind of nightmare you
can’t encounter when you’re asleep.
SCP-5720, the Astronomically-Inclined
Crane, went about its daily work.
The small mechanical crane always occupied
itself with the one task that gave its
existence any meaning: Arranging
esoteric model solar systems. But
something was different today. SCP-5720 put
the final touches on its latest model, and
then lifted its mechanical arm skywards, pointing
directly into the vast and starry infinity above.
But were they stars? No, not today.
As SCP-5720 looked up at the sky,
this time, the sky looked back.
They weren’t stars: They were eyes.
Something was coming towards earth from
the furthest reaches of the outer dark.
An armada of world-enders. Coming from above,
below, and all around, a whole cosmos of supremely
powerful beings, zeroing in on our pale blue dot.
A thought crossed through whatever passed
as the mind of this strange little crane:
“Today is the day your prayers will be answered.”
Followed by another word, ringing loud and clear
and holy as a mighty church bell: “AWAKEN.”
And at that moment, everything did.
Thousands of miles away,
a new God landed on earth, appearing like a great
wall of dense, matted fur descending from the sky.
Ur-An-Uum, the mother of the ones that
came before. After eons of absence,
she had eventually returned to greet
her children, the true rulers and
stewards of this land. But Ur-An-Uum was
surprised and horrified by what she saw.
Their great cities, their sprawling structures,
their beautiful art, and advanced culture...All
gone. Laid to waste by the worthless hairless
apes that once lurked in the forests with the
other animals. Something had happened, something
had...changed. The humans had slaughtered
her people. Destroyed their accomplishments.
Tarnished their legacy. Driven the few that were
left out of their kingdoms and into the forests;
treated them as mere animals, and built their
hideous concrete cities over their bones.
And they had the gall to call
them “Bigfoot”, or SCP-1000,
because thanks to them, their beautiful true
name had been lost to time. She looked skywards
and cried out in despair and anguish at the
loss of her children, inconsolable. But then
she felt something - A glimmer of hope in her
mind, the possibility that things would change.
That the humans would be toppled from their
thrones and true justice would be achieved.
She called out to her remaining
children, and her children answered.
Across the globe, another great entity awoke,
deep underneath a mountain. When it stirred
into life and broke free, it shattered the
entire mountain on top of it, as easily as
you or me displacing a bedsheet. It took to the
skies, massive but unseeable to the human eye.
It soared through the air, gazing down upon the
world it hadn’t seen for thousands of years.
Once it had feasted on the blood sacrifices
of human subjects hoping to avoid its wrath,
but humans weren’t the petty little group
of huddled cavemen that they had once been.
Now, they were in their billions, gathered in
impossibly large settlements. The Entity sought
to find a seat of power that it could influence,
but now, it was spoiled for choice. Eventually,
it zeroed in and found its perfect target:
An SCP Foundation containment site. Here,
it would find a new form to take, and more petty,
pathetic humans to bring under its mighty thrall.
It landed in SCP-765, the Duck Pond.
It’s an anomalous pond that is,
you guessed it, full of ducks, and initially
induces feelings of serenity in its victims,
before later inducing not so pleasant feelings.
When The Entity plummeted into the water,
it began to absorb and bond with the anomaly,
growing to epic sizes as it assumed a form
that the minds of us feeble humans could
comprehend: A giant, terrifying duck.
It released a mighty, earth-shaking quack,
as it plodded across the countryside
to cause mayhem elsewhere.
In Europe, more violent madness was unfolding.
A crimson rooster cawed, then a golden rooster,
and then a rooster of soot-red. Anyone with
a basic knowledge of Norse mythology was
shaking in their boots as a mighty beast
stirred in the heart of a desolate cave.
The chains that had once held the
monstrous dog in place now broke.
It rose and licked its jagged fangs, excited
to stain them with the blood of its enemies.
It was the Great Hound Fenrir, Omen of the End
Times, here to herald the end of all things.
A trumpet boomed across the
globe, with no apparent source.
People in the streets in New York, Delhi, London,
Cape Town, and countless other towns, cities,
and hamlets the world over paused and listened
in confusion. Below them, the great and terrible
Jörmungandr - the thought-to-be-mythological
Midgard serpent - stirred from its previously
eternal slumber and began to uncoil its body.
The shifting caused earthquakes and tsunamis
along the coast of Greenland, as towns
and villages crumbled, killing thousands.
Fenrir stalked across the length of Denmark,
slaughtering and devouring anyone or anything
unlucky enough to cross its path. But it
did not wage its war against mankind alone.
Behind it, a hellish army of burning giants
marched, mighty hands clutching molten weapons.
Ragnarok was upon us now. Odin save us all.
And The Administrator...Slept. She was the
latest in a long line of Foundation staff
members to hold that hallowed position,
and in the dark vistas of her dreams,
a predecessor approached her. He wasn’t the old,
bearded man in a heavy coat that she remembered.
Now, he was wearing a 1950s suit and a
fedora hat, and carrying a briefcase.
That’s right - He’d taken up the mantle
of SCP-990, also known as The Dream Man.
He’s a mysterious figure that appears to
members of the Foundation in their dreams,
warning them of impending disasters that they
may be able to narrowly prevent if his warning
is heeded. Though it often comes at some
terrible cost to the recipient of his message.
This time, however, his message
carried a different tone:
He told the current administrator that
there was no way to stop the apocalypse
from occurring this time, only making
sure that the particular shape of the
apocalypse would be the one most favorable to
the Foundation and humanity’s joint interests.
All this was devastating news that the new
Administrator saw as a grievous betrayal of both
the Foundation’s stances and humanity as a whole.
She refused to accept the idea that the apocalypse
was inevitable, even coming from the mouth of a
former Administrator. As far as she was concerned,
this Dream Man no longer worked
on the side of the Foundation.
He was in league with the world enders,
and she refused to take his deal.
The SCP Foundation would save this world
from the horrors the Lock unleashed,
or they would slide into the darkness with it.
They would never work against the human race.
SCP-343, also known as God, awoke in his cell
in Site-17. The time for fun and games with the
humans at the Foundation had come and gone,
he was going by his true name, Yahweh, now.
He blinked, and in that same instant, he was at
Site 0 - The containment site for another SCP-001,
the legendary Gate Guardian. All the staff
around them looked upon Yahweh in shock,
awed by the reality warper’s sudden
appearance and unable to do anything about it.
But really, 343 was no mere reality warper,
like some had expected. 343 truly was a God - He
just didn’t happen to be the only one in play.
When the Gate Guardian saw
Yahweh now standing before him,
he lowered his sword, spread his fiery
wings, and took a knee in great reverence.
Yahweh spoke calmly, but
with unshakable authority.
“Uriel, it is Time. Open the Gate.
Lead My armies across the Earth.”
The Gate Guardian, Uriel, responded in its booming
voice: “I HEAR AND OBEY, MY LORD AND MY GOD.”
For the first time in recorded memory, the grand
gate that Uriel had always been guarding opened,
revealing thousands of legions of warrior angels
waiting on the other side. They were impossibly
beautiful and powerful creatures. Each one
a vibrant, glowing chaos of wings and eyes,
wielding pure white swords and singing
resounding hymns of war. Soon, the air was
thick with the chorus of rustling wings, as the
angels loosed themselves from the Gate’s mouth,
led by Uriel as Yawhweh’s
general, into the global fray.
Meanwhile, back at Site 10, another
SCP-001, the item that started all this,
The Lock, was entering its next stage of grand
cosmic evolution. Something within the lock
suddenly unfurled, causing a shockwave that
killed everyone at the site and destroyed
the entire building in an instant. Except in
that same instant, all of the Site 10 Staff,
and the building itself, reappeared completely
unharmed in a field in New Hampshire.
Back where Site 10 used to be, The Lock was
doing some terraforming. The ground split
open beneath it into a mighty valley, the likes of
which Earth had never seen before. Lush greenery
sprouted within, and thousands of strange, alien
creatures soon populated this new place. In the
center, The Lock just floated in place. They were
now ready for the first meeting to take place.
Over at Site 2036, Dr. Everett Mann was
working on a number of SCP-098 specimens.
These are frightening creatures
reminiscent of spider crabs,
with blades instead of pincers and a natural
ability to mimic the sounds of their prey.
He was studying the creatures when he got a call,
asking him if the specimens had acted up at all.
They’d already had sudden containment
breaches for SCP-995, a type of dangerous,
carnivorous fungi, and SCP-616, a mysterious
airplane with Satanic elements to it.
Just as Dr. Mann was about to reply, the 098
specimens metamorphosed into many-winged flying
creatures, which flew out of the chamber
with such force that they busted through
walls. Sirens blared all over the facility,
and Dr. Mann joined the many other confused
and frustrated Foundation staff
members wandering the building,
wondering just what the hell was going on
today. They were getting bizarre reports of
unprecedented anomalous activity from all over
the world, with no explanation uniting it all.
According to panicked
whispers across the facility,
Emergency Order Patmos was now in effect,
whatever that meant. The true nature of
what was going on here went over most of
the heads of the SCP Foundation’s staff.
That’s when Mann encountered Dr. Charles Ogden
Gears, who - for such a famously emotionless
man - looked surprisingly worried. Dr.
Mann tried to downplay the situation,
saying they were only looking at a
handful of containment breaches here.
Nothing they hadn’t handled before. Dr.
Gears shut him down with trademark coldness.
Feeling a little more nervous now, Dr.
Everett Mann asked what else had gotten out.
With steely eyes, Dr. Gears
replied: “A whole damn lot.”
Now go check out “Children of SCP-001 The Scarlet
King - Is SCP-999 Really His Son?” and “SCP-001
Ouroboros Cycle - The Full Story Compilation”
for more interesting explorations into SCP-001!